so let's say this I think was trans
McKenna that people have a problem was
something that's real that you can't hit
with a hammer right and I think that's a
real way of putting it it's a real
engine because sparks are real as fuck
dude and you can't wrap your hands
around them but you know they're real
sound is real but we accept it because
we're so used to it the idea of this
invisible thing can could transmit music
and harmony and and beautiful feelings
and make you fucking pumped up and you
here in your car sing another one what
the fuck is that this invisible shit and
invisible shitty but it's coming from
fucking satellites down plus we want to
think that we've got the whole world
figured out we want to think that we
know what's real and what's here and
that all the we consensus all that is
there and I say fuck that I say that's
ridiculous
[Music]
dude we're weird we're weird and we
don't realize how weird we are like
while we're being weird we don't realize
it well well it's you know you got to
work on this life to make money what the
fuck is money who are you what is this
what are we doing here and if you look
at the resources that you have available
to you being 24 hours in a day and a
certain amount your health I think about
what you dedicate most of that resources
to and what's your reward on that will
you get a house you got a box where you
can fucking pass out every night in
front of the television is that what
you're doing
the idea that you need to do anything is
stupid and people used to always tell me
that you like all you need to grow up
you need to grow up what to do what to
die
do I to fall into line to fucking follow
a pattern you don't need to do anything
nobodies do anything you need to breathe
you need to eat food the rest of it is
the structure that we've sort of
invented to sort of give ourselves
something to do when we wake up in the
morning well time to go to work works
not real the car's not real life's not
real this is what's real heart beats and
when those bitches stop all that shit
that you created and stockpiled and
worked for means nothing these objects
don't even exist when you're dead when
you're dead you're gonna go to another
dimension where you can't take this shit
with you you know or not or delight you
shut up what life is about us
interacting with each others and if you
can contribute in any way there's a lot
of people that are great paths that
contribute to this world by being a
great parent by raising someone's gonna
influence other people and a lot of them
don't necessarily get too much credit
for that
that's an incredible resource and the
idea that every one of them is just
fucking up the world whatever the
world's fucked period it's where we're
2014 all right though the direction that
we're going in is fucked wait wait it's
all fucked where's too many of us
there's too much pollution it's not
changing there's nothing as the global
warming is happening whether you like it
or not whether you blame it on
Democratic vagina sponsors whatever that
whatever you do doesn't matter yeah
let's live just live be alive
I could just see like being cut into one
of those YouTube videos that somebody
chose and in the background there's like
people walking fast then the Sun rising
really it's slow and